it's just pain
what
why
there's no good memories this is not the
bomb this is trash
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by trevor noah he's
the host of the emmy award-winning the
daily show on comedy central he's also
written a new york times bestseller it's
called warner crime stories from a south
african childhood trevor noah welcome to
the show thank you very much for having
me you once tweeted that starting your
day with chicken wings is like pouring
paraffin into a ferrari so i take it you
can handle your heat
man i don't even know why i'm here to be
honest with you
i love chicken wings
i like hot food but when it's a
competition that's never a good idea any
hot food eating
endeavor i've gone on has ended very
badly
so this is this is just us beginning
this is just our baby steps
okay this is the beginning
this is nice
it just
like tingles the tip of your tongue you
know
so when we had charlize theron on the
show she gave us a crash course in
afrikaans and taught me how to say yo
massa puss as somebody okay wow all
right is somebody who speaks seven
languages themselves can you give me a
zulu phrase that i can incorporate in my
everyday life
you'd use it for your show
[Music]
yeah which means i'm hungry ah
you need that all the time which south
african delicacy do you think deserves
more shine slap chips bunny chow or
biltong biltong i think biltong deserves
a lot more shine because like here's the
thing bunny chow i've seen versions of
it in the world you know people take
bread i put a bit of curry inside of it
i've seen some version of that uh [ __ ]
chips i mean it's just like how you you
know it's not french fries it's just
bigger portions of potato that have been
cooked you know
but biltong is amazing man it's like i
remember when i came to america and
someone was like have you tried jerky
and it's trash jerky is trash i don't
care who you are that jerky is trash
it's got a whole bunch of like sodium
and whatnots and like sugar and why you
have sugar in your meat what like what
is this
whereas biltong is just spiced dried
meat it is the most delicious thing
you've ever eaten if you eat it right i
guess the name as well bill tong right
that's not a sexy name
you know what i mean like if your if
your girlfriend said to you tonight me
you bill tong i'd be like i got plants
you see
see it's branding that's the problem
no it's nice flavor i can taste the
pineapple
[Music]
so you're a self-described roller
coaster [ __ ] who dreams of touring the
best thrill rides in america what's been
your most harrowing amusement park
experience
i went and i rode harry potter
outside um
universal i think it is
i love roller coasters and the harry
potter ride is one of the best and the
ride stopped in the middle
and first i was like oh this is part of
the ride it's crazy
and i was like no no it's not
something's wrong yeah and then you just
hang there and then you go what what
happens now you're like on a plane they
tell you hey if [ __ ] goes down
something's gonna fall you're gonna do a
thing you put your head down and you
know yeah they don't tell you anything
before roller coasters go have fun be
this be this tall and have fun how is it
resolved like did somebody get on a
ladder and press a button or did it just
start moving again after a while it
started moving and i was with a friend
of mine who is terrified of any type of
ride and his screams
made me afraid because at first i was
like we'll be fine and he was like
and then i was like we're gonna die
we're gonna die this is like you gotta
contact fear it's you know it's like in
horror movies i feel like half of the
fear is the person who's screaming you
know if everyone is just calm like we
might die i'd get through it
but the contact fear is what terrifies
me
let's see shaquanda
it hits the sides of your tongue really
nicely
like in the sauces so far it seems yeah
it's got an okay flavor i'm still on the
classic i mean that's winning for me
right now we'll take it
so since taking over on the daily show
there's been a massive explosion in the
number of programs that have political
commentary and satire at their core do
you think that this snowballing of
political punditry is helping us to
think more clearly be more informed or
do you think it might be having the
opposite effect oh it's interesting
i think it's good you know i think it's
good to have as many shows as possible
especially shows that cater to young
people you know for so long people have
made it seem like politics is what you
do when you're old but politics affects
your entire life in fact i feel like it
should be the other way around i feel
like old people should be like i don't
care i'm almost done it's weird to me
that like super old people like i'm
gonna vote and change this world that
i'm leaving soon why why would you care
if i was old i would not give a [ __ ] i'd
be on roller coasters going crazy
did jon stewart give you any advice for
how to avoid becoming that old angry man
screaming at the clouds oh no he said it
was going to happen john said i'm
leaving because i'm old and angry and
you're young and happy so um enjoy it
while it lasts
that was his advice
his advice was just like you know try
and enjoy it for as long as you can
don't don't let the anger be your
overriding emotion you want people to
tune in so that they're not angry
anymore by the end of the show
and that's what i try and do
one unintended consequence i think is
that there are a lot of super funny
comedians who seem less interested in
doing the lighthearted entertainment
that they used to right do you think
that that's sad in a way or is it naive
to expect anything different well i
think
people forget that comedians are human
beings we're living in the world you
know so
jim gaffigan super funny guy doesn't
like talking about politics but at some
point he's going to be like yo i got to
say something ricky gervais another
person hates talking about politics but
at some point even he was like guys
we're just gonna act like this is not
happening so i get why some people be
like oh my favorite comedian started
talking about politics it's like yeah
but maybe it's because the politics has
started affecting your favorite comedian
that's probably what it is you know
[Music]
what what kind of name is that lucky dog
year of the dog
thai chili i don't think chai is ever
spicy
[Music]
it's got a nice it dances on your tongue
nicely
that's my favorite spicy food the one
that dances on your tongue yeah you just
want like like you know you want to be
like friday stairs dancing across your
tongue
all right good good spicy food
so when we had bill burr on the show he
said that doing stand-up in new york is
like performing at a women's college and
i'm just curious
from your perspective do you find that
audiences in the u.s are any more or
less sensitive than the ones that you
encounter internationally or i find it
they just care about different things i
find it depends where you go
you know i've i've gotten rid of like um
categorizing america as one giant you
know one monolith when i came here i had
those ideas
i've realized now america is basically
50 countries masquerading as one
even in new york like going from like
long island to brooklyn audiences are
completely different i always say this
with comedy
everyone thinks a joke is funny until
it's a joke about them
right that's pretty much what it is
you know it's like hot ones everyone's
like yeah that's cool until they're the
one eating the food and they're like
this
this is not cool man
it's not cool
los calientes
i'm always hesitant to say how hot or
not something is sometimes it sneaks up
on you
that's a guy who's been around hot food
before that's a veteran take right there
all right trevor we have a recurrent
segment on our show called explain that
graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so i'll
bust out the laptop i'll show you the
picture you just tell me the bigger
story does that sound good
all right laptop please
[Music]
this is just from my instagram not my
pawn hub account right
yeah no just from your instagram okay
but i did check that out
this is you at the met gala with chrissy
teigen and john legend so that picture
was actually one of my favorite moments
because
i had just gotten to america really like
for the daily show and this was like one
of my first public outings i had no clue
what this was or who these people were
you're just like you're just seeing all
the celebrities and people always think
you should become a celebrity overnight
no right no there's levels there's
levels so you like walk into a place and
then if you see rihanna it's not like
you should be like hey ree how you doing
girl no no you don't and so
when i was leaving the event afterwards
john legend and chrissy teigen saw me
and then like i think it was christy she
was like hey you're the guy taking over
the daily show and i was like yeah and
she's like don't [ __ ] it up and i was
like uh okay she's like no i'm kidding
come over here you've got friends like
no i don't have friends but i mean i do
but not at uh at the mecca and she's
like come on come on hang out with us
how you guys doing they're the nicest
people you've ever had yeah john and
chrissy are just like the
nicest celebrities you will ever ever
meet in your life so that's what that
picture was speaking of epic nights
that's uh lewis hamilton's world
championship trophy i think that was in
austin but he's a friend of mine he's a
world championship formula one racing
driver and really one of the best we've
seen in a generation amazing driver in
the wet which is really hard to do
especially in formula one
he was he was racing in austin he was
like hey do you want to come check out
the race uh hopefully i'll win the
championship and i was like yeah okay
i'll come
and so i went
and he won and then when we went down to
congratulate him they were like yo do
you want to hold the trophy i was like
yeah of course i want to hold the trophy
you trust me with the trophy and we're
like yeah we trust you with the trophy
and now they don't know where the trophy
is
detroit hellfire
i would say this is this is my my
favorite like all-around flavor of a hot
sauce you know
so far it has like a beautiful body to
it
it accentuates the chicken that's a nice
flavor man that's really good
so the title of your book born of crime
refers to the fact that as somebody who
had a black mother and a white father
that you were representing a crime that
could have been punishable by up to five
years in prison right you've made an
interesting point about how in some ways
you prefer the racism in south africa
compared to the racism in the united
states right how do you unpackage that
for someone who thinks that all racism
is the same well you know what you've
got to think of it like this think of
racism like hot sauce you know there's
some hot sauce where they tell you it's
hot sauce but you can't really tell
you know you put it on your tongue it
doesn't happen but then maybe tomorrow
when you go to the bathroom you'll be
like oh that was hot sauce i don't like
that
i want to know when it's happening that
this is hot sauce you get what i'm
saying yeah so yeah i i grew up in a
world where people were blatantly racist
for the most part if they were and then
you know what what i like about that is
i know where we stand we can work off of
that i can talk to you as a person i can
try and figure out where your racism
started or what makes you more racist
and then
and then we can move forward the hardest
person
to to to try and change is someone who
doesn't believe they're racist or
engages in racist ideas
that uh that aren't direct because then
you know what i mean someone's like i'm
not racist i'm not racist at all i just
think that sometimes black people you
know
those ones
good luck man
that's that day after hot sauce day
after hot sauce racism i don't need that
in my life
trinidad scorpion
oh lord here we go
okay
oh
okay
um just wanna don't breathe yeah hot
sauces
feeling your nose
yeah
immediate
mmm
oh [ __ ]
oh man
you feel that i feel that
this is a hot sauce that doesn't even
doesn't even it's not in your on your
tongue it's burning the top of your
mouth why would you on the top of your
mouth spiciness
[Music]
this is unnecessary
so you seem to have a real knack for
interviewing people whose views are
diametrically opposed to in these tribal
times what advice do you have for
talking to someone with whom you share
almost no common ground
i think the key is to listen our
instinct as human beings is to first
tell a person why they're wrong
but i find
if you listen to them you can understand
a little bit of where they're coming
from and then maybe that can give you a
little insight or a way in to finding
common ground that then can lead you
somewhere else
that takes you feel your time right now
it
uh your tongue it's it's starting to
tingle out
but you know sometimes there's this
expectation from the audience that
you're gonna like body slam this person
or destroy them in this debate if you
come to my show as a guest i'm going to
treat you accordingly you know i don't
want to destroy you i want to engage
with you and i i think i think a lot of
the time as people
if you have ideas you believe in you
should be willing to engage or you
should be willing to test those ideas
against somebody that that you don't
agree with
hitting i'm hitting are you hitting the
water
does water help
so
i always have this thing when i hit the
water i know that fans are big that
actually makes it worse it spreads
though it's thoughts
no i know i know but like so i have like
uh there's tons of insufferable hot
sauce experts that are always hitting me
with the tips so you're trying them
maybe on some level but also i think
psychologically which i think is more
important anyway the water does help me
for whatever reason i know that it's
against science but in my brain that's
how it works okay
all right
this next one
is to bomb beyond insanity
man all right
[Music]
oh this is horrible
oh lord
oh [ __ ]
this is my what is this
there's no food it's beyond insanity but
there's no food
oh man i got that weed cough
oh man
now that you're in a position to afford
the finer things in life is bologna and
brown bread still better than any
michelin-starred restaurant bologna
brown bread and margarine which you guys
aren't familiar with because you guys
use butter we couldn't afford butter so
we had margaery still one of my favorite
meals
simple it's effective and it's delicious
unlike this [ __ ] which you've just made
me eat what is this
god damn this is horrible
for the uninitiated how do you describe
the gastronomic experience of eating a
goat's eye
um
imagine a bouncing ball imagine taking a
bouncing ball putting into your mouth
and biting it really hard but then it
pops and explodes
and all the snot from a child's nose is
in your mouth
that's what eating a goat's eye is like
delicious i know that you're a big fan
where does the heat that we're at right
now compared to the hottest at nando's
oh my lord
here's the thing nando's gets really hot
but it has flavor
it makes you think of something else
oh lord
oh jesus
it's just pain
what
why
there's no good memories
this is not the bomb this is trash
[Music]
oh
ah
okay
i'm trying to think if i should rinse my
palate for this or
just add to it so far you're on a no
water no milk yeah track it is rarefied
air i like to i like to taste the
flavors what's this next one
this is pucker butt chocolate plague
from smoking ed curry
you joining me i'm coming all right
[Music]
okay
we're back in flavor
still very hot very hot
but the flavor
which plane with fire incident as a
child brought you closer to death the
time that you were playing with black
cats and they exploded taking your
eyebrows off by the time that you burned
down a shed with a magnifying glass i
would have to say the time i was playing
with black cats so i poured them all out
into a pot plant ooh and made a super
made a super yeah and then and then but
i i i was trying to light one in my hand
i was like you know as a pause i was
like let's just enjoy this moment
and it blew up in my hand and i dropped
the match into the pot plant i was
trying to gather all the gunpowder
and it exploded up and burnt my eyebrows
off
but i didn't know
so my mom heard a loud bang was like wow
and then my cousin screamed
and my mom came running outside and
she's like what happened
and i was gonna be in trouble so i
turned around and i was like nothing
and she's like what did you do it was
like nothing
and she's like something happened i was
like why would you say that she's like
cause you don't have eyebrows
and i was like what what
you know she's like go to the bathroom
and look at what you look like busted
and i went and literally i was like i
had like charred pieces and then no
eyebrows irrefutable so yeah
that was probably it
what's the bag like for doing voice over
work for black panther
you just want me to to ignore that
you're shaking the last one up
[Music]
you haven't shaken any of them up you're
gonna shake up the last one so this is
the last dab we call it the last dab
because it's tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last wing you
don't have to if you don't want to
trevor noah
you say that as reverse psychology
now i have to do it
basically what you just said to me the
translation was if you would like to be
a little bitty you're welcome
that's what you did so now i have to
indulge with you
good health is weird you know what it
looks like it looks like my little
brother's diaper
whenever i change that's concerned i
would find this inside his diaper that's
what it was see that over there yeah
all right
this is it cheers my friend cheers my
man
oh lord
okay
are you okay yeah
i think you're holding up better than me
you look a little stressed
i'm not gonna lie for a white guy this
is super impressive
thank you trevor i'll take that i'm
being for real
all right trevor noah here we are at the
summit of spice mountain and as we've
learned today you can speak on almost
anything but i think that you're at your
most eloquent when you talk about taking
a [ __ ]
you've called going number two profound
a powerful experience and it is an act
that makes us forget our airs and graces
so now with your gut throbbing
cinched yes tortured by the hot sauce
yes can you tell the people why are we
most ourselves when we're letting the
caboose loose i'll tell you why it's not
even a disgusting thought
i think as human beings we spend so much
time
pretending you're taught to act from the
time you're a young child your parents
teach you a certain thing your teachers
your friends everybody and then you
develop this persona about who you are
that persona lives with you it changes
and it augments as you grow
but there's one place where we are
honest
i don't care who you are
and that is
when you are taking a [ __ ]
it is just you and yourself
you sit there and you are honest you are
humble
no one shits cool from me all the way to
the queen we all [ __ ] the same
same squat pose same everything have you
seen a dog when it takes a [ __ ] i don't
care if it's a pitbull or chihuahua
they've all got that look on their faces
[Music]
that's what [ __ ] does you it reminds
you that we're all the same nobody's
better than anybody else at the core
we've all got that stuff that comes out
of our butt
words to live by from trevor noah and
look at you my man 10 chicken wings up
10 chicken wings down and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you trevor noah thank you
very much this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life um i've got an
arena tour that's really fun it's called
loud and clear i'm going around america
and the world doing stand-up comedy
everywhere from north carolina to abu
dhabi so check out trevonoa.com if you
want to come and watch the show very
funny is what i've been told by the
audience as they laugh while i tell them
the jokes
i've got
oh [ __ ]
oh the hiccups are coming
oh i should have mentioned i get hiccups
when i eat spicy food
oh [ __ ] wait wait wait
all right i'm good
i'm good
i get hiccups and i forgot about the
heck
all right at the finish line all right
so i'll see if it shows
if i still have a voice
all right good job trevor oh that's the
hot ones jesus
yeah the hiccups
when do you shoot today
uh
in about an hour
aloha spice lords thank you so much for
watching today's episode this is shawn
evans checking in with three tips for
surviving summer remember to wear
sunscreen at least an spf 50 if you're
anything like me don't forget to stay
hydrated when you're out there on the
beach and always have a bottle of the
sauce of summer los calientes and never
go anywhere without it
heatness.com heatness.com to order los
calientes it's muy delicioso
[Music]